another giant corporation that has
clamped down on people's ability to
speak freely is Disney because Disney
got all in this quote-unquote don't say
gay thing here in Florida DeSantis hit
them back and I said it you can find
videos from six months ago or whatever
it was that my feeling was that not only
was this not going to go well for Disney
and when then we saw the the stock go
down they released what was the movie
they released this past week that
absolutely bombed you know what it what
was it called Strange World absolutely
bombed because parents have had it with
the woke stuff and the whole movie was
was all the woke nonsense but I said it
about six months ago that at the time
Bob chapic was the uh was the CEO that I
felt it was going to take him down
because once you've let the woke virus
in once you have the diversity inclusion
and Equity offices in the building and
everyone's focused on how many black
people are doing uh animation for this
movie and how many gay people do we have
here and have we chopped off enough
penises and all of those things I did it
again every now it always makes me think
of you I don't know why
um
once you do that once you take your eye
off the mission and the mission at
Disney should be to make great movies it
should be to make great TV shows to have
the best theme parks possible to not
wreck Star Wars and make every Marvel
movie exactly the same but once you've
brought in these ideas of equity and
inclusion you're just damaging the
product I felt that it was going to take
out Bob Jacob japeck and of course yes
he did resign and now they have brought
back former Disney CEO Bob Iger I guess
they got to hire a guy's name Bob and he
did his first town hall uh and basically
said we're gonna ease up on the woke
stuff because at the end of the day he's
a businessman and you're not going to
believe this guys businessmen often look
at the numbers and they go boy we did
something this way and we lost a lot of
money if we do it that way I think we're
going to get more money so
Bob Iger there's a virtual question many
cast members had wished that Disney
stayed out of politics Will Disney stay
out of making political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that
I mean they're going to take him out too
right the more that he lets the inmates
run the Asylum and maybe they're on
notice now like guys everyone shut up
about this stuff but they'll go after
him because they are on a I would say
cult-like mission to indoctrinate people
into their woke ideology and there's an
awful lot of them who still work at
Disney but he wants to you know he wants
to kind of quiet things down let's not
be as so perhaps overt about it but
what's the reasoning for it is it
because Disney as an organization
suddenly saw the light or is it because
Ron DeSantis fought back Ron DeSantis
took away their special tax benefits he
took away other benefits that the state
was giving Disney because they chose to
get in on this nonsensical thing and
then what happened well the citizens of
Florida kind of dug it because the guy
wanted a freaking ridiculous Landslide
by 20 points